hey 42 so it's been a week now since
time began what have you been doing
since the dawn of time oh you didn't
know time only began lamb person I know
it sounds a bit mental but can you prove
me wrong it may seem unbelievable what
can you honestly say that it's not
theoretically possible that everything
on everyone you've ever known your
memories possessions and the universe
itself didn't just spontaneously pop
into existence this lust firstly you
have memories before last Thursday sure
but how could you prove that all those
memories didn't just come into existence
in their current state at the time of
creation which was of course last
Thursday this is called last Thursday
ISM and there's a group of people who
honestly believe that the world came
into existence plus birthday snow people
have taken it a little too seriously
but at its core it's simply a force
exercising don't worry I'm pretty sure
like most people are that the universe
is 13.7 billion years old except these
people but it's interesting to think
about isn't it because last fuzzy ISM is
impossible to prove wrong it doesn't
matter what piece of evidence you come
up with no matter how clever or complex
it may be it can simply be explained
away by saying yeah but that piece of
evidence only came into existence last
Thursday if the research is to be
believed then roughly 25 percent of
Americans believe that the Apollo 11
moon landings were faked
the tractors site apparent evidence such
as the American flag was waving in the
footage but how could it when is no wind
on the moon
apparently the whole thing was filmed in
a specially built soundstage in
Huntsville Alabama all meticulously
directed by Stanley Kubrick they also
filmed the Apollo 12 mission while fair
eruptive because you know they had paid
for the studio time and didn't want to
waste it the low gravity scenes were
faked using hidden cables that would
hoist the actors up into the air and
apparently the whole film has been
slowed down to achieve the low gravity
effect if you speed up the footage by
2.5 times it shows the astronauts
walking
pace that would be normal for Earth's
gravity steals conspirators also argued
that there's no stars visible in the sky
considering that the moon's atmosphere
is nowhere near as thick and viscous as
Earth it wouldn't block any light and
when standing on the moon you should be
able to see every star NASA's excuse was
simply that the low quality of the
photography used washes out the stars in
the final image but some of the
photographs taken were of a higher
quality yet there were still no stars
and much lower quality images have been
taken here on earth that show stars in
the sky and then there's this famous
image taken by Apollo 11 astronauts
showing a moon rock but there's a lot of
Sigyn printed on it as if it's a marker
for a studio prop eerie well there you
go there the moon landing was obviously
faked or was it know just know it feels
enticingly Romantics you believe that a
conspiracy theory of this magnitude
could be true the idea that the US
government is hiding such an enormous
secret from us seems so much more
interesting than the reality that we
have created the technology to reach the
moon and pass every scientific
mathematical and biological barrier
requires to do so that should be the
real story here but conspiracy theories
are simply sexier than physics so Who am
I to definitively say that these
landings were not faked well an argument
should only remain in arguments until
evidence presents itself on one side or
the other
that is absolutely irrefutable on the
sufficient scrutiny if a piece of
evidence cannot fee disproven then we
simply must submit to it and accept it
until a time comes if it does when that
evidence can be disproven what am I
talking about I'm talking about what
Armstrong Collins and Aldrin left behind
when they visited that lump of rock out
in space an hour before they finish
their final spacewalk in the moon
surface they left a mirror on the ground
but not just any mirror a retro
reflector
you see a normal reflection returns any
light at an angle exactly equal to the
angle of the light hit it up a
retro-reflective always returned delight
to the exact same angle of the source
now you'll need a megawatt laser but if
you did have a laser powerful enough and
you shot it at the moon at the exact
location where the retroreflector was
left behind and you set up a detector
powerful enough to detect the returning
photons then you could actually detect
the laser being reflected back a planet
Earth from the moon nothing in nature
has the reflective properties to return
a laser all the way back to Planet Earth
from the moon therefore there has to be
a man-made object on the moon placed
there by somebody this experiment has
been successfully carried out hundreds
of times with the same positive results
and no stars were visible because the
astronauts were exposing through the
light areas of the frame the astronauts
in the foreground is they had been
exposing to the blackness of space the
foreground would have been blown out
with white dynamic range just wasn't as
good back then as it is today that's
just basic photography there's also the
fact that the special effects technology
requires to fake a moon landing did not
exist in 1969 it just didn't nowadays it
will be a breeze was in a strange irony
in 1969 the human race had invented the
technology to travel through outer space
and land on foreign bodies yet we didn't
have the technology to realistically
fake it
CGI wasn't first used in film until five
years later in the 1973 film West world
but forget CGI the fake footage would
have had to been shot by mr. Kubrick in
Co on a high-speed film camera so the
footage could then be slowed down by 2.5
times to imitate the moon's
gravitational field what here's the
thing high-speed film cameras didn't
even exist in 1969 the technology wasn't
there it's one thing shooting film it of
to 30 frames per second
what shooting it's 60fps or a book is a
hole of a ballgame technologically and
to put things into perspective the 1969
Apollo 11 mission was shot on a 10 FPS
film camera that's just how far off the
technology was back then NASA may have
been very smart but they didn't have
technology from the future over sex
Apollo missions 382 kilograms of moon
rocks pebbles and soil samples were
collected and brought back to earth
totaling 2,200 samples many of which
were distributed to scientists
universities and research centers all
over the world including Russia yes
America gave lunar samples to there at
the time direct enemy did Russia examine
the rocks and announce that they were
simply earth rocks accusing NASA of not
actually going to the moon no and if
anybody had a motive to disprove the
moon landings it was Russia but what
about America and probably directed the
world number one conspiracy food that
the 9/11 attacks were an inside job
polls showed up 54% of Americans believe
that 9/11 was orchestrated by the
American government themselves they
accused the government of staging the
attacks to provide the grounds for
military strikes in the Middle East and
the conspiracists have a handful of
really solid and rather convincing
pieces of evidence that supports their
theory and of course there's the old jet
fuel can't melt steel beams chestnut
roughly an hour after the two planes to
the north and south towers of the World
Trade Center both towers collapsed in
seconds what the way in which they
collapsed was peculiar they collapsed
inwards and fell straight down in a
perfectly vertical fashion almost as if
it was caused by a controlled demolition
using a series of well-placed thermite
explosives inside the buildings many
argued that the temperatures at which
jet fuel burns are nowhere near high
enough to melt the structural
steel beams that kept the tower standing
and many eyewitnesses survivors and
emergency services who were in the tower
just before it collapsed have reported
experiencing explosions seconds before
the building's fell so did the u.s.
government plant bombs inside the
buildings beforehand two train pass off
a controlled demolition of the results
of a terrorist attack was it false flag
operation even will trace into building
7 which was not hit by a plane collapsed
after a few hours and the only damage
which is sustained was from the debris
falling from the Twin Towers yet this
small amount of debris somehow managed
to level a steel frame structure the
towers 3 4 5 & 6 received far more
damage from falling debris yet their
structures remained intact in February
2005 a fire started in the Windsor Tower
in Madrid Spain engulfing the entire
building in flames the fire burnt for 24
hours before it was distinguished and
yet it didn't collapse it had to be
demolished afterwards so how come some
relatively small office fires brought
down wt7
and then there are several of a major
problems America has the largest and one
of the most sophisticated air forces in
the world their f-15 fighter jets can
fly at a staggering 3,000 kilometres per
hour the maximum speed of the Boeing 757
passenger jets which were hijacked is
980 km/h and these huge jumbo jets and
knots exactly stealthy they were flying
through some of the world's most
restricted airspace vastly off their
original course for up to an hour and a
half that kind of behavior doesn't go
unnoticed by air traffic control yet on
the day the f-15 combat jets capable of
striking targets the size of a coin 4
miles away using laser-guided missiles
fail to intercept and stop any of the
four hijacked planes you
attack not only with a fighter jet
scrambled far too late but may think
that they were actually told to stand
down and do nothing
whilst the attacks unfolded unimpeded by
the military the first and second
attacks on the Twin Towers happened
earlier in the day would a full 1 hour
and 45 minutes pass between when the
first plane hit the first tower and when
flight 77 hit the Pentagon many people
believed there was ample time for the
military jets to intercept and shoot
down that plane if they were given the
correct orders at the correct time which
they weren't I mean it's not as if the
third rogue hijacked planes intentions
weren't known the attack on New York
City had been broadcast on every major
news station for almost two hours by
this point so it's inexcusable for the
government and military to let the third
attack happen but speak to anyone in the
world about 9/11 and everybody has their
own unique version of what they believe
happened that day and why if you want to
dive even deeper then you can the
conspiracies get even more far-fetched
there's a large group of people who
believe that there were no planes that
day yes that's right
no planes they insist that what we all
saw hit the second tower on television
was in fact CGI I'll go no further on
that but for every conspirators out
there there's someone willing to argue
against them and for every piece of
evidence that it was an inside job
there's an equal and opposite piece of
evidence suggesting that it was a
genuine terrorist attack now I'm not
here to train persuade you one way or
the other there is substantial evidence
on both sides of the party and in truth
to this very day nobody apart from a
select few knows who was behind the
tragedies that day but what I do find
interesting is why so many millions of
people do Hemanth we believe in
conspiracy theories wouldn't it be so
much easier if we just ignore the shady
irregularities and accept what the
idiot tells us or maybe it isn't in fact
I think it's quite the opposite it's far
easier and more tantalizing to believe
in stories than the truth the truth
requires extensive dedicated research
nobody got time for that
whereas all it takes was to believe in
conspiracies is a few pictures taken in
the wrong light or Chinese whispers from
a guy who worked at the mall who knows a
woman who once dated a man who was the
CIA it's just easier not to mention far
more interesting but what's the
psychology behind this why do people so
readily rebel against Authority and
they're so eager to believe and it good
old conspiracy Maslow's hierarchy of
needs was created by psychologist
Abraham Maslow it depicts the five goals
that every human must satisfy to achieve
happiness and life satisfaction it
starts with the most fundamental needs
and then each level of the pyramid must
be satisfied before you can pursue the
next level think of it like the game of
life if you like physiological needs are
the most important such as breathing
food water sex and sleep and next is
safety it says a lot that the most
important of our basic needs after sleep
food and drink is safety
we must feel like we're not in danger
and our brain knows it whenever a
catastrophe happened our first fort is
with our own safety and then the safety
of our loved ones after the event passes
our brains scramble to try and find a
reason a cause and a perpetrator behind
the event we are just unable to relax
until we know the exact people and the
chain of events that led up to that
disaster and that's because our brains
seek comfort and security when our brain
experiences fear our amygdala is
activated which in turn activates the
parts of our brain that process
information this is our brain responding
to that fear by attempting to figure out
why the bad thing happens its own nerves
are most primitive psychological needs
to think that the world is entire
chaotic and random and at any moment
something terrible could happen that
affects us outbreak of war terrorist
attacks or a leader being assassinated
the idea that there is no order or
structure behind all of this and it's
just a winds of the global machine that
is planet Earth is a truly terrifying
fort to most people many people would
rather believe that some evil overlord
or an omnipotent shady cabal is running
the scene and orchestrating everything
like a gigantic spheres of play even if
they are Lizard Men it doesn't matter
because it makes us feel secure and
comforted there is certainly a morbid
sense of security in the knowledge that
if something terrible happens at least
someone with a modicum of stability is
behind it all and it's not just caused
by random number generation or a rogue
group of religious extremists who can't
be controlled and that's why we believe
in conspiracy theories because it gives
us a reason and outlet to blame things
upon it fulfills our basic need for
safety in a really messed-up way at some
points most of us have believed in a
conspiracy theory in a casual manner not
really giving it too much thought and
there's nothing wrong with that because
some of the things because some of them
unless nothing wrong with that because
some of them have turned out to be
correct we're not always crazy
remember Watergate and MKULTRA people
sounded crazy believing these things
happens and then the truth was revealed
the people were right all along but then
there's the other end of the scale that
goes beyond rational thinking we all
know or have encountered at least one
hardcore conspiracy nut who genuinely
believes that the world is run by a race
of shape-shifting Illuminati lizard
people who faked the moon landings under
9/11 attack while simultaneously hiding
a master race of aliens in area 51 I'm
controlling all our minds of chemtrails
and fluoride in the water so they can
start a new world order in which
west's president and we're all tracked
by microscopic computer chips inserted
into us via vaccines what drives someone
to be so certain in these rather
outlandish beliefs the dangerous think
about strongly believing in a conspiracy
theory is that it can slowly shut down
your pragmatic thinking and any
information or evidence which
contradicts a conspiracy theory can
simply be explained away as part of the
conspiracy
oh so you think they'd let mirrors on
the moon that's what they want us to
think dude it calls the backfire effect
and it's the fact that when people are
given evidence against their strongly
held beliefs they instantly reject that
evidence and believe in their thing more
strongly religious people are experts at
this but we won't go into that the more
people who argue with conspiracy
theorists the more strongly they believe
their conspiracy it's a vicious cycle
and research has shown that if you
believe in one conspiracy you're
significantly more likely to believe in
others but many conspiracies from
history are turned out to be completely
true and who knows what secret document
will be leaked tomorrow or the next day
proving a conspiracy to be true that
sounded wildly unbelievable before
curiosity may have killed the Cup but
all the other cups certainly paid
attention thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video then please click
here to support me on patreon so I can
give it to my Illuminati overlords I
mean so I can make better videos click
here to watch another video and if you
haven't already don't forget to
subscribe